so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the original Supergirl
Kara zor-el and what I'm hoping is that
at the end of this you'll have a strong
understanding of her character as well
as how she helped to evolve the Superman
universe with her initial introduction
created by Mort Weisinger and Otto
bender in 1959 Kara zor-el came out of
DC's attempt to introduce a female
Superman because editor Mort Weisinger
had made it his mission to add something
new to the Superman landscape every six
months once he had taken over the title
in 1959 and because young women partook
in comic books but largely kept their
interest confined as stories involving
romance Weisinger look to expand on the
Superman mythos and reel in the young
female demographic all at the same time
looking to the popularity of 1943's
Action Comics issue number 60 which saw
Lois Lane becoming superwoman by way of
a dream and Superman issue number 123
otto bender set the stage to introduce a
super girl by providing Jimmy Olsen with
a magical artifact and this story titled
The Girl of Steel an unnamed town is
flooded due to a torrential rain with
Jimmy Olsen flying the mobile newsroom
Lois Lane arrives for the purpose of
covering the footage but it's thrown out
of the helicopter by violent winds
coming to her aid after witnessing her
fall because of Comics Superman rescues
her during which time she uses about
marrying him replying that he and Lois
would never work out due to the constant
danger in Superman's life and that only
a woman of equal power could stand
alongside him Jimmy Olsen overhears the
conversation and states that have given
the opportunity he would grant Superman
the very Supergirl that he's looking for
transitioning to a landslide that occurs
but as witnessed by Superman he
alongside Jimmy Olsen make their way
through the rubble and rescue a trapped
archeologist providing Jimmy Olsen with
a reward for his efforts the man
provides him with an old Indian relic
with an inscription stating that once
every century it grants three wishes to
its wielder if they rub the gym
recollecting the conversation between
Superman and Lois Lane Jimmy Olsen uses
his first wish to create a Supergirl to
fight alongside the Man of Steel and so
with a plane flying out of control the
next day Superman rushes them to save it
but it's beat by the arrival of
Supergirl helping a surprise Superman
land the aircraft
Supergirl states that the reason
Superman had never seen her before is
because Jimmy Olsen wished her into
existence after rubbing his magic totem
working together
Superman shows her the ropes of being a
hero and that her initial endeavor
involves a safe that has been locked
trapping a clerk inside using their
x-ray vision they try to disarm the lock
but because of supergirls and
experienced her beam crosses with
Superman and the vault door explodes
while it doesn't kill the clerk Superman
uses the
as an instance to teach Supergirl the
lessons of controlling her powers
however while Superman maintains his do
a life of Clark Kent during an outing
with Lois Lane
Supergirl flies by and recognizing who
he is by way of her x-ray vision and
Superman's suit under his normal clothes
revealing his identity
Superman becomes angry at Supergirl and
refuses to work with her any longer and
so going on patrol by himself after
discovering that a train bridge had been
damaged and will cause the coming train
to crash Superman flies in to repair the
tracks however the villains in question
arrived and drop a rock of kryptonite
which begins to weaken him coming to his
rescue
Supergirl picks up the Kryptonite
sacrificing her life in the process due
to her exposure to the radiation
returning to Jimmy Olsen he uses a
second wish to end her suffering by
wishing her out of existence now
following this story because it sold so
well
DC took the next step and in Action
Comics issue number 252 in 1959 a
genuine Supergirl was introduced and her
first appearance which also came with an
origin story
Supergirl crash lands in a ship which
was overheard by Superman travelling to
its source he finds the vessel destroyed
but is also met with Kara zor-el as she
explains during the destruction of
Krypton which taught Clark Kent sent
away as an infant a city containing a
scientist along with a handful of others
have been flung into space while the
landmass had been irradiated due to the
destruction of Krypton and turned into a
giant chunk of kryptonite LED shooting
had been placed on the ground since the
radiation can't penetrate led following
this the scientists and citizens
survived for several years in the vacuum
of space using a food dispensary for
nourishment during which time is a
relative of life producing a child named
Kara during their early years a meteor
shower struck the landmass and destroyed
the lead sheathing resulting in the
Kryptonite radiation permeating the area
with only a month to live zor-el began
to work on a ship that could be used to
send Kara away and ensure her survival
and during this time kara and her mother
scoured the spaceways for a suitable
location eventually stumbling on earth
recognizing kal-el as the son of jor-el
and the cousin of Kara because the
Earth's lesser gravity granted him
superpowers after which he had served as
a super hero Kara and her mother agreed
that this is the best location to send
her to and so with the ship completed
Kara leaves her family behind and is
sent to earth where she crash-landed at
the start of the store
following this Superman comes to the
conclusion that instead of starting her
career as a superhero right away instead
she Nisa spent some time honing her
skills and adapting to the use of her
powers providing her with a secret
identity in the form of Linda Lee she's
enrolled in Midvale orphanage where
she's instructed to keep her presents
hidden until such a time as she has full
control of her abilities and the world
is ready for another super-powered
Kryptonian now following this initial
introduction DC was met with a litany of
letters from fans of the Superman series
praising the idea and requesting more of
the same and so rolling our character
over as a backup feature in Action
Comics for 10 years until issue number
376 in 1969 the stories of Supergirl
remained under the control of Otto
bender with Jerry Siegel taking over
after issue number 261 during vendors
run Carrie maintained the identity of
Linda Lee but worked to aid other kids
from the orphanage and achieving
adoption and in the process staved off
her own as an example in issue number
253 she speaks to the boy named Jimmy
who reveals that he doesn't think he'll
be adopted due to the fact that he
doesn't have any talents that would
attract prospective parents introducing
him to a farming couple since the only
thing he learned was how to milk cows
Jimmy's eventually adopted allowing
Supergirl to stay at the orphanage while
these stories also saw her sneaking out
of the orphanage to experience the world
the underlying theme here was largely
self-discovery both in terms of how
great people could be but also how
deceptive they could be furthermore
vendors set the stage to allow Supergirl
to step into her own character with
issue number 258 farewell to earth
during this story Supergirl had saved a
boy from a falling tree and in the
process encountered Krypto the Superdog
for the very first time while flying
around and seeing the sights Supergirl
encounters Superman who chastises her
for leading Midvale orphanage and
risking the world becoming aware of her
as punishment Superman places her in a
makeshift vessel and sends her to an
asteroid where she's banished from
returning for a year during her exile
she uses her telescopic vision to
observe her friends and witness a forest
fire breaking out taking giant icicles
from the asteroid and fleeing them at
earth the ice melts over the fire
putting it out in the process
s and so receiving a letter from
Superman by way of Krypto Supergirl is
informed that the asteroid will be
bombarded with kryptonite radiation
ordering her to return to Earth she
arrives but realizes that her absent
from Earth has resulted in the orphanage
sending out a search party making her
way back her sudden arrival sparks
headlines with various members of the
news coming to attempt to interview her
during this time
Clark Kent appears and begins to
question why it was as she shows no
signs of starvation or injury after she
had concocted the story of being lost in
the woods resigning himself to the fact
that she had failed in her attempt to
keep her identity secret
Supergirl reveals that she and known
Clark Kent was Superman all along due to
the fact that she had tried to damage
his glasses when he inspected her skin
for injuries after failing to achieve
this she realized that the man was
wearing two super glasses which led her
to realize that it was Superman and
pressed by her ingenuity and attempting
to keep her identity secret Superman
informs her that the entire situation
was a test to see if she could keep her
identity as Supergirl hidden and
maintained her secret identity as Linda
Lee as a result he allows her to begin
accompanying him on missions in secret
so long as no one sees her now following
this while stories like Supergirl versus
the Superman Emergency Squad and super
girls darkest day served to expand on
her role as a superhero on earth DC was
also looking for a way to provide
legitimacy to her character and slowly
continued the trend of moving her away
from Superman and into her own realm as
a standalone hero and so with Action
Comics issue number 285 in 1962 Jerry
Siegel wrote a story that saw Kara being
adopted by Fred and Edna Danvers
changing her name to Linda Lee Danvers
DC said about demonstrating to fans that
Supergirl was indeed standalone to this
end because her biological parents were
presumed dead following the destruction
of Krypton Weisinger and Siegel felt
that this origin was too similar to
Superman looking to correct this problem
with Action Comics issue number 305 in
1963 titled the girl who hated Superman
Siegel introduced a series of dream
sequences which would reveal the super
girls parents were actually alive coming
to a head in issue number 310 the story
saw her parents trapped in another
dimension called the survival zone
created explicitly for this story and
his conclusion
Supergirl rescued her parents but
because fans had grown accustomed to the
relationship formed between Kara and the
Danvers her parents were moved to the
city of Kandor and Supergirl remained a
child of Fred and Edna Danvers now by
1969 in order to gauge the popularity of
her character DC wolf Supergirl over
into adventure comics with issue number
381 as a series that was used as a
testbed for popular concepts like
Superboy and a legion of super-heroes in
order to gauge fan desire for more
content because action comics made it
impossible to determine whether the
series popularity was due to Supergirl
or Superman DC had hoped that during her
stay in adventure comics line they could
develop a legitimate answer to the
question of whether or not she was truly
a popular character to this end under
writer Cary Bates DC maintained the
element of Supergirl that connected her
to young readers like her romantic
relationships with boys at her life
after college this coupled with the fact
that come at the superhorse
and streaky the super cat continued on
alongside Supergirl in her new stories
meant that there was virtually no
deviation from the content and action
comics to the adventure comics line as a
result the popularity of her stories
increased due to the consistency that
came with him lasting until 1972 with
issue number 424 following the
retirement of DC editor Mort Weisinger
and as part of editor Julius Schwartz's
revamp of the Superman franchise and
were to make him more down to earth the
Supergirl title was handed over to Joe
Orlando and Mike Zukowski looking to
eliminate unpopular titles and continue
the more popular ones in November of
1972 DC released Supergirl number 1
however because the new direction of
Superman's series was reviled by fans
who prefer the massive scope and size of
the character and conflicts the
Supergirl series was effectively guilty
by association and began to fall out of
popularity as a result with issue number
10 in October of 1974 DC cancelled the
solo series renaming Superman's pal
Jimmy Olsen to the Superman family
Supergirl was rolled over into the new
anthology which served to provide a
series of stories independent of each
other
focusing on Superboy Jimmy Olsen and
Lois Lane along with Supergirl herself
however because they continued change in
storytelling and the down-to-earth
nature of the characters weren't wildly
popular among readers while he remained
as editor until 1986 Julius Schwartz was
forced to reinstate many of the larger
than life stories of Superman and the
various characters including Supergirl
finding a renewed popularity in 1982 DC
elected to attempt another solo series
titled the daring new adventures of
Supergirl written by Paul Cuban Berg and
drawn by Bob Oscar in truth because
Supergirl had spent so much time in the
Superman family anthology DC had
effectively turned the title into a
victim of itself while Superman had
retained his own solo series due to his
position as one of DC's premier
characters Supergirl had constantly
struggled under various writers looking
to give her interesting stories that
made her separate from Superman in terms
of interest but the same in terms of her
powers as a result for the first 12
issues the Supergirl title struggled
with mediocre sales with the publication
teetering on the edge of cancellation
and sent with Cooper Burch staying on as
writer and alongside carmine infantino
who had been brought on to replace Bob
Ozma the physical appearance of
Supergirl and the title of the comic was
revamped eliminating the premise of
daring new adventures and simply calling
it Supergirl
Kara's physical appearance was also
changed to the now iconic uniform
working together and introducing the
famous red headband as a symbol of
Kryptonian citizenship the stories of
Supergirl flourished with fans welcoming
both the more adult-oriented battles and
compelling new look however with crisis
on Infinite Earths knocking on the door
the following year the title was
suddenly canceled in October of 1984
with issue number 23 the reason for this
was because in the eyes of DC while
Supergirl was growing and becoming more
engaging of a character for fans of the
Superman family the Man of Steel himself
had actually been dropping out of
popularity using the logic that interest
in Superman was failing due to an
oversaturation of super-powered
Kryptonian switch should destroy the
uniqueness of the character under Marv
Wolfman DC used the crisis on Infinite
Earths event to eliminate the concept of
Kara zor-el as Supergirl entirely
because a decision proved to be one of
DCs most controversial and that longtime
Supergirl fans had felt betrayed with
the time and money they had spent and
new fans who had just gotten into the
character were left hanging when John
Byrne took over the Superman series and
was tasked with revamping all aspects of
the title debates reign supreme when
Supergirl was reintroduced as a man-made
shape-shifting artificial life-form who
for all intents and purposes was an
alternate reality clone of Lana Lang the
girlfriend of Lex Luthor from the same
alternate universe while the disembodied
spirit of the now dead Kara zor-el made
occasional appearances in the
post-crisis continuity between 1988 and
in for matrix served as the super growth
of DC's continuity while steps were
taken to attempt to define her character
and replace Kara including a merger with
the human girl Linda Danvers and allure
to take on a near identical appearance
to Kara in the end the matrix Linda
Danvers version of Supergirl was not a
Kryptonian and therefore not a true
Supergirl and so in 2004 due to the
post-crisis continuity of Supergirl
becoming chaotic and confusing from
stories involving merged personalities
and shared bodies under mitre Jeph Loeb
DC looked to wipe the slate clean by
launching a wholesale reboot of the
Supergirl line and reintroduced Kara
zor-el to this and during the Batman
Superman publications which saw a series
of team months between the two Jeph Loeb
wrote a six-part story titled the
Supergirl from Krypton introducing her
for the first time as an actual person
following the crisis on Infinite Earths
story Kara ship is shown to have crash
on earth with Batman following her
character's accidental trail of
destruction as she stumbles throughout
the world eventually capturing her and
using green kryptonite to knock her out
and analysis of her DNA by both Superman
and Batman leads to the conclusion that
she Superman's cousin from Krypton and
so for the following five issues Jeff
loved continued the series and having
Kara inducted by Wonder Woman of the
Amazons pursued by Darkseid to become
one of his warring Furies and eventually
step into her own as the Supergirl of
Earth in essence for those of you who
had seen that Batman Superman apocalypse
animated feature that film was based on
this story
now following her reintroduction to the
DC landscape the issue remained as to
what would happen to the matrix Linda
Danvers version of Supergirl who had
appeared after crisis on Infinite Earths
answering this question in two phases DC
first began working on building Kara
zor-el up by having her take part and
Geoff Johns run of Green Lantern which
had been outselling Superman and Action
Comics and seemed to be the best place
to provide her with the most exposure to
readers the second phase came in the
September 2008 story
reign in Hell by writer Keith Giffen
which didn't really kill matrix off so
much as shove her into the closet to
make way for Kara zor-el and that matrix
was quite literally resigned to existing
in hell taking the next step of
establishing that Kara was the
definitive Supergirl and 2005 Jeph Loeb
helps her relaunch the Supergirl solo
series
writing the first five issues during
these stories
girl experience a Tour de France and
that issue number one saw her teaming up
with Power Girl a version of Keira
herself from the earth to continuity as
well as a Teen Titans in issue number
two and Nightwing in issue number four
as a result of these stories fans were
ecstatic at seeing the return of a
genuine Kryptonian returning to the
mantle of Supergirl and by issue number
three sales of the Supergirl comic
tripled selling over 100,000 issues
considering this to be a welcome
reception DC kept that trend going and
between 2005 and 2011
Supergirl solo feature lasted until
issue number 67 but he was cancelled as
part of DC's line wide reboot with the
new 52 with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end and I won't
catch you guys later peace